hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast decoding how clapeyron is
transported to distal synapses along
axons presented by our Chung Ganguly
postdoctoral scholar University of
California San Diego
I am Alexis Clark corrales of lab rats
and I will be your moderator for today's
event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's labret is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation this click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Ganguly I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello everyone thank you for
attending this my presentation and my
name is Arjun Ganguly and I'm a
postdoctoral fellow in University of
California San Diego and today I'm going
to talk to you about the work which I
did in in dr. Raja Troy's lab and the
Royal lab works on how proteins are
transported along axons and today I'm
going to talk to you about this very
interesting protein called clathrin
which I'm going to talk to you about how
it's transported and why we think this
transport is important for the
physiology of the neuron so if you look
at how proteins are
our target are transported to synapses
you know the picture which everyone has
in mind is this idea of this long neuron
which has the cell body where all you
know all the proteins are synthesized in
the ER Golgi and they move along the
axon to the terminals where you know you
have the pre synapses and this occurs by
the the action of anterograde motors
kinesins and retrograde motor Dining's
so this is what people always think
about that all proteins which are
synthesized in these in the cell body
are transported to synapses by this fast
transport now fast transport does
actually convey proteins which are
important for synaptic physiology to the
nerve terminals but that's not the only
way these proteins move or that's not
the only mode of transport these
proteins state to from cell body to the
synapses so now if you read a bit of the
literature you will realize that most of
these proteins which are essential for
synaptic physiology move through this
method or by this mode of transport
called the slow axonal transfer and so
what slow axonal transport so if we
let's let's look at a little bit about
you know how to slow axonal transport
was discovered and what exactly is slow
axonal transport okay so this is from a
traditional later radio labeling studies
which were done back in the eighties
early 70s late in and the 80s where
people would inject these radioactive
isotopes into the cell body of a neuron
in vivo mostly and then they would let
the radioactive probes incorporate with
newly synthesized proteins which would
be transported along the axons and
synapses and they would take off
sacrifice the animal take the you know
the injected part of the neuron the cell
body the axon and the synapses and then
they would use a scintillation counter
to essentially look at the
the peak of radioactivity and what they
found was yes most proteins the first
wave of proteins which move along the
axons is the sparse axonal transport
which is where the proteins move at
around 500 to 400 millimeters per day
but there's a slow wave which comes days
after the fast transport waves move is
gone and this in this mode the proteins
move much slower so what we if you look
a little bit into you know what's or the
ratio of proteins which I was talking to
about in the introduction as to the
ratio of the synaptic or proteins which
are transported by fast transport and
slow transport and if we look at this
figure here where you can see these
chromatograms you can see that when you
look at the axon and when you look at
the synapse you and take these segments
separately and do a scintillation count
for the radioactive label proteins you
can see that obviously in the fast
transport there are proteins which come
to the synapse but if you look at the
gel picture on the right which has and
if you look at the synaptic fraction you
see there are a lot more proteins which
are coming to the synapse via the slow
transport or it takes when I say slow
transport it just refers to the rate at
which they arrive so they arrived much
later but a lot more proteins arrive to
the synapse by slow transport versus
fast transport so that's where I'm gonna
start my like story and we're gonna see
sorry we're gonna see what you know how
this interesting protein fraction is
transported so before we go into you
know looking at transferring transport I
would like to point out some caveats
about you know slow transport so why
hasn't slow transport being studied as
well as fast axonal transport because
everyone everyone wants to study fast
axonal transport because you can
Chula is the cargo and you because they
are these distinct vesicles which can be
tracked by knife microscopy and you can
essentially track them over time whereas
wide can we do the same with slow
transport so what's the problem so I'm
gonna go into a little bit of the
problems which are which people working
in the field of slow transport encounter
and then then I'm gonna talk to you
about how we kind of try to address
these or we we think we address these
problems significantly well so I hope I
can convince you by the end of this talk
that slow axonal transport is as
important as fast axonal transport so
the problem with slow axonal transport
is that radio labeling studies which
were done in the 80s can't really tell
you anything about the dynamics of the
protein or half of the transport of this
protein as you know is like you know you
can only get these simulation counts or
the activity counts of the radioactive
isotopes but we don't have any
information about how they are moving
what are the proteins which are
essential for their movement any of any
of those details and the one problem in
the field as I was talking to you
earlier about was that the slow
transport proteins are mostly soluble
proteins they are cytosolic proteins so
they have this diffused glow if you tag
a soluble protein to GFP let's say so
instead of the distinct vesicle like
punctate which we see in when with fast
axonal carbo's like you know
mitochondria or cell amplifies in P 30
car even a PP like those appear as
distinct vesicles or puncta whereas when
you tag it to a GFP or RFP for live
imaging but when you do the same for a
slow transport protein you just see this
diffuse glow across the axon and that
makes imaging or any
kind of prediction about what's
happening what are you know like what
are the factors affecting their
transport almost impossible and more
importantly not much is known about you
know sorry I just think I hit a wrong
arrow I'll just go back so what we tried
to do was to okay so and also the
composition of the slow transport
complex is unknown so we don't know what
moves in this slow transport cargo big
besides like a few selected proteins
like clathrin and sin absent so we
wanted to also address that question so
the to address the first part or the
second point on the slide here which is
about this diffuse globe what the lab
has done in the past is instead of
tagging the soluble protein or the SC of
the slow transport protein to a GFP just
a regular GFP of protein we use the
photoactivatable GFP which was a jet
telecom discovered or developed in the
laboratory of jennifer Lippmann got
Schwarz and what that allows us to do is
we can just photo activate a small
segment of the axon and only that
segment of the axon which has been photo
activated by using a UV light would be
green and the rest of the axon would be
completely dark so that allows you to
track the subset of photo activated
proteins as they move along the axon and
this is previous work from the lab and
they the the work kind of shows that if
you track the movement of the
photoactivatable gfp-tagged to a soluble
protein you see that over time the the
mean of the fluorescence intensity which
is kind of shown by this yellow or
dotted line in the center is moving as
you know that the frames move on or you
keep imaging the same region of the axon
it moves to the right so here to the
right basically it means that it's
moving more distal from the cell body so
and it's moving distally to the priests
and abscess so this we call as I'm
through great transport and if it would
have moved to the left it would be
called retrograde transport because it's
moving towards the cell body so using
that this was a previous study from the
lab well one of the slow transport
proteins synapse in which is essential
for the presynaptic physiology of
destroy the presynaptic bouton is was
shown to be moving in a neck and
triggering direction so now remember
that although the like when you photo
activate this region you still see a
green diffused segment it's only a very
small segment of the axon which you've
image over time and only this segment
would be seen to be moving to the right
which would be integrity over time so
this kind of allows us to you know keep
a track of the the segment which was
photo activated instead of having the
entire axon being completely green which
is impossible to you know analyze for
any quantitative studies so why do we um
oh and I can forgot this is just a
control experiment from the same paper
from the lab showing that if you have a
just a soluble pH gfp and in the neuron
but no which is not tagged to a soluble
as a slow transport protein you don't
see that ship so here you would see that
the black line over time is essentially
flat so which means the the center of
the fluorescence has not moved it has
stayed the same so it's basically not
moving on either directions and I think
I've kind of forgot to tell you a little
bit about how we do this how we do these
experiments so we
use cultured hippocampal neurons from
mice embryos and we translate the
neurons grow let them develop their
axons the dendrites and then we use a
lipo factor main based which is
essentially just a way of making holes
in the membrane of because all the
membranes are by layered lipid membranes
so we use these chemicals called ally
perfect amine which would make hole in
the met transient holes in the membrane
of the of the axon and the cell body of
the neuron where the the DNA where which
is our slow transport protein tag to GFP
would enter into the cell in the cell
body and then it would be synthesized
using the cell's protein transfer
translation transcription and
translation system and then it would be
expressed in the in the entire axon and
even distally in the synapses so that
allows so the reason we use these
cultured neurons is that these allow us
to perform high-resolution live imaging
and the ability to track these proteins
over specifically in the axons which we
identified by they're more for
morphological characters and using this
method we I'm gonna talk to you about
today's experiments and all of these
studies have been done in these cultured
neurons so why do we need to look at
clattering so if you know clathrin is
critical for endocytosis and synaptic
vesicle recycling and if you look at
this neuron here I mean not only is such
an important for the endocytosis at
dendritic spines and in the cell body
for the transfer transfer and its
receptor uptake it is also essential at
the distal presynaptic Bouton's where
it's essential for presynaptic release
which is important for conveying the
action potentials from one cell body to
the other to the
which is downstream of it and this
electrical continuity would help the the
information flow from the brain to
whichever part of the body you are
talking about mostly like distal
components so and also if pulse label
our radio labeling studies have shown
that clattering does in fact move in
this slow transport complex so we knew
that clattering is a slow transport
protein and we knew it's very important
for physiology but what we didn't know
is how it moves and you know why it
moves slowly and what is the
significance of this movement for
synaptic physiology so as I mentioned
radio labeling studies cannot visualize
external transport and for the
visualization of clattering and we so
the the radio labeling studies cannot
visualize the axonal transport so in
this talk I'm going to talk to you about
how we visualized this slow transport of
clathrin and define the transport cargo
complex so we started by doing these
just the staining x' for endogenous
clattering in the in the in the
dendrites and in the axon axons and what
we found was if you look at the middle
panel here which is for showing
clattering staining by using endogenous
antibodies is that clathrin appears as
these punctate dots along the dendrites
and it also has these pumping dots along
the axon so they look pretty much the
same and what we were wondering was that
is there any difference between the
clattering dots in the dendrites versus
the clathrin dots in the axons because
if there weren't any differences we
would not because if you look at the the
the dendrites there the flat trend kind
of you know moves in both directions but
we know that in the axons it selectively
moves in an anthro great direction
so there has to be some differences
which allow for this to happen and
that's what we were trying to study so
what we did was basically we tagged
clathrin with a gfp construct and this
is all previously shown but if you look
at the dendrites what we found was and
we actually confirmed those published
studies which is which is great so if
you tag clathrin to gfp and if you look
at the dynamics off the clathrin or the
gfp-tagged flatterin over time in the
dendrites we see you can see the red
arrowheads on this slide which point to
the the state where this um in oak
Lateran the signal essentially
disappears and we know from a previous
study is that what happens is that the
cat clathrin forms these are tri skia
and they form this nice octahedral
structure which is kind of shown in the
image
in the cartoon below and clattering
under words like cycles of assembly and
disassembly so we would see these dots
appear and or these signals appear and
then whenever the cage disassembles the
signal would disappear so we saw that in
the dendrites but then we wanted to see
what's going on in the axon so that in
the axons they look like this
and if you if we track the the movement
of these dots over time we can draw this
thing called a kinda graph which
essentially shows the proximal distal
orientation from the left to the right
and the time axis on the from the top to
the bottom and we can see these
individual particles shown by the red
arrow heads moving in the aggregate
direction and we also see some movement
moving particles here which start so if
you look at the top arrow head it
there's an example of particle which
starts moving up while it's paused and
the next one where it's it stops moving
after it has moved a distance so it kind
of shows that the classroom in the axons
is very dynamic they move and bonds some
stop moving after a while and some start
moving after pausing why so we
characterize the the moving particles
and we saw that there are forty percent
of the particles which are mobile the
rest are stationary and if you look at
the ratio we see that there's a 60/40
ratio and 60% of these particles move in
the attribute direction now we what
wanted to do this in a very unbiased way
and we just wanted to look at the
transport of clathrin in along the axon
and we just wanted to do this without
tracking individual particles which can
obviously make you know like you can
have a certain bias because you want to
show or highlight something so what we
did was we tagged clattering to be a GFP
which I talked about in the introduction
which is just a photoactivatable platen
and we just activated
clattering particles in a subset of the
axon using a UV light the 405
wavelength and we tracked the movement
of these particles and this is an
example of the actual particles moving
over time and you can see again with the
x-axis showing you the time and the Y
showing the distance you can see that
the the the clattering particles move
with the attribute bias and we
quantified this and we also showed with
a dip with another method using a photo
conversion strategy where you
essentially have this protein called
tendrá which is green normally but when
you use the UV light you can photo
convert a subset of those green
particles to red particles and you can
track the movement of only the red
particles over time and using both these
methods we saw that the the clathrin
particles which are tagged to be a GFP
and Endre are both moving in the antrum
grade direction and now this
quantification is unbiased because as I
told you
the mean intensity of these particles
would would be tracked using the you
know the methods which was described in
a previous work so what we did next was
we looked at whether this transport is
actually dependent on fast transport
because this was again another study
from the lab where we show that the slow
transport proteins are dependent on fast
motors and their interaction with fast
carbo motors so we disrupted the
microtubules by using this drug called
cortisol and we saw that there is no
transport after nuchal result treatment
of clattering tag the GFP which shows
that this transport is dependent upon
microtubules and probably also on the
motor proteins walking along these
microtubules and then we also use this
drug called b.fa which would essentially
block all vesicles which are delicate
derived from the ER Golgi are network
and we also saw that by disrupting the
biogenesis of this of these vesicles
from the ER Golgi you essentially kill
the transport of these of the clutter
intact the GFP so what this suggests is
that there it's essential for the
microtubules to be intact and we also
probably need the vesicles which are
generated from the ER Golgi for the
movement of this platform transport so
we won't wanted to go a step further and
we wanted to look at the the composition
of this complex and we did this first by
looking and the ultra structure of
clathrin in the axons by using 3d storm
and by 3d storm if you can look at this
the panel labeled D where you have beta
to spec per spectrum and you have four
frames along the axon which is shown on
the top we can see that the beta 2
spectrum is along the rim of the axon as
expected and if you look at the clathrin
which is the signal in the middle panel
we see that there are these
sickle like structures which we call
just for clarity clattering transport
vesicles which we see along naive axons
these are not close to the AIS but these
are like about 200 microns from where
the cell body is so these are like
native axons these don't have you know
like active these are native axon so
basically if you look along the axon
shaft off of neurons we see these
CTV's which are kind of you know in
inside the diameter of the axon and they
look like these vesicles so to go a step
further we wanted to look at what these
phase vesicles look like at even high
resolution and we did this by using
electron microscopy and this was done at
NC Mir with Mark Michael it Marta
Lisbon's in collaboration with my Marta
Lisbon's lab and we just used this apex
tagged a version of GFP clathrin so we
could this is an enzyme which just helps
in turning da B and hydrogen peroxide
just when you add that you have this
dark signal which shows so it shows
where your clathrin tagged particle is
and by using this if you look at the the
middle panel the number labeled with the
normal Roman numerals - we're looking at
a transfected neuron and you see these
black dots and if you look at number one
and two zones on the rightmost frame we
can see these clathrin-coated pits in
the dendrites so we know that it works
as expected because we can see these
coated pits along the axons now we
wanted to look how they look along the
axon because that's not really known so
if you look at the so this is again a
neuron on if you look at D on the right
this is like a low mag image often
transfected neuron the same transfected
neuron shown here in C and if you look
at the axon of that transfected
I'm just going to show you the hi mag of
views of segments 1 & 2 if you look at
the segment's 1 & 2 share on the bottom
left and right we can see these dark
structures which are in the orange boxes
and highlighted by these white arrows
arrowheads and these are what we call
the coated pits now again these are
several micrometers
away from the cell body so these are not
endocytic pits which we see in the AIS
or the dendrites and these are just
native axons and we don't see a
connection between these pits to the
membrane which suggests that these are
unique transport vesicles which are
moving along the axon and if we look at
these orange the boxes I am going to
show you even higher map view of this if
you look at are two of these on the Left
we have the magnified views and what we
can do is we can make like the skeleton
which is on the right hand side and we
see that these look like a ring with
these spokes coming out from the outside
on of its edge and this structure is
very similar to what you would see or
what you would say a ported vesicle is
and here's another example on the bottom
with the red arrow where you can
actually see the vesicle with the spokes
along the side and we think this is an
exact and as you can see it's not close
to the the membranes which are marked
from the on the top and the bottom and
it's kind of in the middle so we think
these are the coated vesicles are moving
along the microtubules using motors and
these are very similar to
clathrin-coated vesicles but distinct
from endocytic pits so now - we wanted
to look at the composition of this
complex and what we did was we
essentially did we took axons from the
sciatic nerves of mice and we did a
fractionation to isolate all the soluble
protein facts
and then we I peed or did you know
precipitation with this latter antibody
and a control antibody which shouldn't
bind clathrin and then if you pull down
clattering the hope is that you pull
down the proteins which interact with
classroom and using this strategy and
then we drew these samples and we send
them for mass spectrometry where we can
essentially identify all the peptides
which interact with clathrin and we can
subtract those from the ones which are
nonspecific which would be binding to
this with the control antibody so when
we did that we and sorry this was done
in collaboration with John eats his lab
at Scripps Research Institute and these
are just the left hand side shows the
Western blood showing that the I P word
and the bottom panel shows the the raw
peptide values of clathrin and the itg
is showing how specific this interaction
was and then we just looked at all the
proteins which were significant in
tractors with clattering and I can't go
through the whole list but there's some
essential you know group of proteins
like we have like some micro tubulin
tractors we have actin proteins we have
some motors we have some enzymes which
are not surprising because they are all
known to move in slow transport we have
heat shock proteins which are also known
to move in heat in slow transport and we
also have these proteins which are
essential for the assembly and the
disassembly of the collection clathrin
coat so this was very exciting but what
was very interesting was that we also
found some new proteins in this complex
which have not been described earlier as
components of the endocytic bits or
coated vesicles so we think this is a
unique complex and what we hypothesized
was that if we target specific proteins
in this complex we would be able to you
know see or impair or enhance the
transport of classroom so one target was
this important which this interesting
protein called
- in six which is known to bind to which
is shown here in the purple at the
bottom and it it is known to bind to
actin filaments and it's also known to
interact with clathrin-coated vesicles
so we hypothesized that if we remove
this interaction maybe we will you know
remove some of the inhibition which is
holding the the platinum coated vesicle
and preventing its movement along the
axon so what we did was we use this the
SH RNA approach where we knock down the
expression of a protein and then we look
at the transport of clathrin back to GFP
so this is a control and all the red
arrow heads are showing you the moving
particles and when we knock down the
myosin 6 so essentially we reduce its
activity significantly what we saw was
that there is a huge increase in the I
hope you can see I didn't put the arrows
in here but you can see there are many
more particles which are moving on the
on the graph on the right compared to
the one on the left and it just shows
that removing the function of my sins or
inhibiting the function of myosin six
big increases the number of moving parts
from particle and this is kind of
quantified and I won't go into too much
of the detail but essentially the
take-home message is that if we disrupt
mice and six we increase the transport
of claps and along axons so it's all
good that the trunk clattering is
transported along axon but what's its
final destination and we know that the
most important part of a axon are these
distal presynaptic Bouton's
which are essential for synaptic
physiology because they form the
presynaptic complex of a synapse and so
when we were looking at this we kind of
asked ourselves is this axonal clathrin
transport complex is this supplying
clattering to the distal synapses and
what we did was we looked at a distal
reason axis
if you look at panel a on the top we
have synaptic vison which marks these
synaptic Bouton's and they are all in
red and if we look at the bottom panel
of a it's that clatter intact to gfp and
we see these green dots and we see
clathrin in the photons and i don't have
a movie for this because it doesn't like
show very clearly but we can show that
the classroom in these synaptic Bouton's
is very dynamic and if you look at see
the the dotted gray lines are the ones
which are synaptic Bouton's and we can
see though as though as indicated by the
white arrows that you will see examples
where the clattering coated vesicles are
moving into the photons and in the
bottom panel where they are moving out
of the bouton so we think it's a very
dynamic system where clattering is
moving from the axon in to along the
along the axon and it's kind of
delivered at the butonce
and some of it is probably transient
some of it stays around in the bouton
some of it probably moves away we don't
know exactly how long they stay in the
buttons because it's kind of hard to
track individual dots over time but we
know that there is some dynamic
interactions and we kind of also have
some evidence from our studies to
suggest that the movements are decrease
you know as the neurons get more and
more mature so they are more dynamic in
younger neurons and as the synapses
mature and and form their connections
these movements become less frequent and
just a final slide to kind of highlight
that you know this is probably the
synaptic clutter in which we see is
actually a integer multiple of the
intensity of a single or the average
intensity of a single axonal fraction
particle so what we observed was that
the average intensity of traction at the
synaptic Bouton's
was around seven times of that of a
single
clathrin-coated clattering transport
vesicle or a CTV and so we kind of
hypothesize that there are multiple see
TVs which are captured at a synapse
where they may be essential for synaptic
plasticity so to conclude my talk while
trying to summarize the highlights so we
show that clathrin is transported as a
highly stable complex and it does not
disassemble during its transport like
the dendritic platform complex
suggesting it's a very stable complex in
axons and this appears varies in the
axonal fracture and appears very similar
in morphology to coated vesicles which
along in which have been described
previously in the literature we show
that myosin 6 acts as a tether to stall
these fluttering movements along the
axon and if we inhibit - and 6 we have
more clattering moving in along the
axons and finally we show that
presynaptic lakshman is an integer
multiple of axonal clattering particles
intensity which kind of suggests that
the individual CTV's along the axons are
probably going to the synapses and
helping in a presynaptic
neurotransmitter release so I would like
to end with with with this
acknowledgment slide with all my
previous lab mates and my mentor dr. Roy
in particular and I would like to also
thank my collaborators who at the
Scripps Research Institute and NC Mir
UCSD and I thank you all for your
attention and I can take questions
whatever questions you have thank you so
much thank you dr. Ganguly for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button once there's
many of your questions we type or
so let's get started our first question
is what is the difference between slow
and fast transport and what makes slow
transport slow that's actually a great
question and - not much is known about
slow transport but I think one
interesting difference which we have
uncovered about slow axonal transport is
that slow axonal transport is modified
you can say like a modified form of fast
axonal transport so in fast axonal
transport the motors always are
associated with this vesicle and this
interaction is very long range or
persistent over time whereas in slow
transport what our studies have
uncovered is that the motors and the
vesicles you know you can call these
cargo complexes or cargo vesicles the
contraction time is very transient so
what actually happens is that these
vesicles or these cargos keep attaching
and detaching
from the the motors which move them
along the axon so in effect what happens
is that it's essentially moving by fast
transport but just because these
interactions are so transient and that
that causes like the cargo to move X
amount of microns over a much longer
time and that's what we think is making
it slower it's not and and we actually
don't know much about what mediates the
interaction or what kind of controls
these transient interactions between the
slow cargos and the motors but we do
know that the slow cargos move via these
motors which are also employed in fast
transport so I think it's just the
interaction and the nature of the
interactions which makes fast and slow
transport so did dr. Ganguly our next
question is is the axonal clathrin same
as clathrin-coated Piltz that's again a
very good question and to be honest i
don't really know the exact answer for
it i mean from our electron microscopy
studies as i mentioned
in my presentation it looks like these
are coated pits now we don't know for
sure whether these are endosit vesicles
or coated pits as you know the ones
which are responsible for transferring
acceptor uptake at the cell membrane we
have the composition of this clathrin
complex and we see proteins which are
not present in the core the endocytic
pits so we believe that these are
clathrin-coated complexes but we don't
know for sure whether these are coated
pits or not so you know right now to the
best of our understanding we think that
this is a unique complex which is just
transported along the axons and it's
independent of the coated pits what is
the role of microtubules and actin
filaments in the transport of Katherine
yeah that's a that's a good question and
we actually if you remember one of my
slides we show that I actually show the
data to show that if you disrupt the
microtubules you essentially stop the
slow transport of clattering along the
axon which is kind of consistent with
what we know because the the molecular
motors need these microtubule filaments
to you know move along or walk along or
whatever you call the motion to be so if
you disrupt these by using some kind of
toxins if you disrupt the microtubules
you are essentially going to stop the
movement of the motors and if you stop
the movement of the motors you're going
to stop the movement of clattering so in
effect if we disrupt the microtubules we
don't see any movement of clathrin in
the antegrade direction but actin is
actually quite interesting so if you can
if you go back to the slide where I was
talking about Mars and six so now myosin
six is known to interact with actin
which all myosin six or all myosin
motors are known to interact with some
actin filaments so our hypothesis was
that if we disrupt the the myosin six
and the interaction with the actin
filaments we will see kind of a
increased transport or that's kind of
what we saw in the presentation so we
saw that if you disrupt my
you see the there's a increased rate of
transport for clattering but when we did
the same experiments and we disrupted
actin we did not see that much of a
dramatic effect so I don't really know
whether disrupting actin will you know
stop transport or enhance transport but
if we inhibit myosin which is known to
interact with actin we do see a increase
in our collateral transport so we think
it may be not just the actin but there
may be like molecular motors or players
which are you know essential for the
interaction of this complex with that in
filaments and like Marcin six and if we
disrupt these complexes or these
proteins the effect would be more
dramatic than rather rather than just
disrupting the acting actin filaments
and dr. Ganguly it looks like we have
time for one more question have you
tested the role of other proteins in the
clathrin complex
besides myosin 6 on clathrin transport
yeah again that's that's a that's a
great question and we are actually
working in the lab so or two you know
like pursue that question and you know
we have this mass spec data which I
talked about in the presentation and we
have a huge list we kind of started with
myosin six because it seemed like it
wouldn't it's known to interact with
actin and then you know like we kind of
hypothesize that if we inhibit this
interaction we may see an increase in
transport or something would happen but
there are so many molecules which are
there in the complex it's not possible
to test every one of them but we have
tried our testing a few heat-shock
proteins which you know in a in a
previous study from our lab we show that
these are essential for the composition
of the slow transport complexes but we
didn't really see an effect of
disruption of heat shock proteins on the
transport of clathrin now it may be
because you know like the inhibition was
not complete or we were probably
targeting
you know like a like a different form of
HSC 70 but we tried myosin six and HSC
70 but we are actively pursuing other
molecules which are present in this
pattern complex so that's an ongoing
investigation I would like to once again
thank dr. Ganguly for his presentation I
would also like to thank Lab Rats for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I won't to
everyone note that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you will receive an
email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye